i'm with marcia batuski of orange poland
marcia before we talk further tell us
about your position in the polish market
yeah so orange poland is is the
incumbent so we are obviously number one
on the fixed telephony and fixed
broadband and on top of this we are
convergent since the very beginning with
mobile operator which is now the number
one number two
on the market providing the solutions on
convergent including the the television
the 3p 4p
packages and
interesting for the today's conference
with some beginnings of the of the ftth
in the network uh the the vdsl being
already present there since three four
years yes where do you see ftth coming
into that portfolio it must be a very
challenging market
well first of all the market is very
challenging on every single area so we
have today just to give you the
dimension
and to give some eager to the non-polish
viewers of this of this video you have
all you can eat crossnet mobile
telephony voice
sms mms and and data for roughly
10
12 euros per month so so it's a very
challenging country to get the
profitability and with the fiber to the
home the the case is even is even worse
given that on top of this it's a country
where basically all the big cities are
already covered by the ktv with doxy3 so
a very high speed broadband coming from
from the cable cable operator so tough
market but still we we started to
transform the copper internet into the
copper vdsl solution now i think there
is a moment where you will have
two elements in parallel so the lte
so the lt 800 auctions just as of today
running so once those frequencies are
delivered we will have the lte fix lte
most probably
taking a lot of space in the rural areas
but in the same time if you think about
the real future
we have to invest and and most probably
we will invest quite heavily into the
into the fiber yes i guess you you the
benefit of having all the technologies
is that you are well positioned to deal
with the geographies and the and the
where the customers are located
yeah but but basically true for the
technologies but at the same time
customers are looking for the same
quality of service
and this is the difficulty of the game
because today yes we could cover the
poor peasants with the with the wireless
lte which theoretically gives you nice
throughputs but but in the future if the
peasant who has no access to the theater
and cinema day today he would even
consume more of data normally
than someone living in the center of
warsaw that's why we own them a proper
connection and there is the difficulty
of the uh
of the business case to provide those
villages and in poland we have 50 of the
population living outside of the big
cities provide them with it with a very
good quality and and that's the main
element so today it most probably will
be for some time still wireless
but we have to start to invest into the
into the fiber than to to cope with the
with the networks lte networks being
more and more congested in the future so
so final question then so is rural that
the biggest challenge or is it competing
in the cities would you say
well i would say
today we have the same challenges as the
whole europe
we have the challenge of consolidation
so we have four mobile players we have
still a number of uh of fixed players we
have the ktv having dominant very much
dominant position more than 50 market
share in every single of the big polish
series so there's an element of
consolidation
without this consolidation we will have
problems with first finding
big companies big enough to invest
and second of all every single time we
will invest so for instance orange will
invest if you have a number of small
players they will push for the maximum
of the regulation to get access to those
networks which will worsen our business
case which then
will stop the investment so
consolidation is number one at the at
the national level hopefully one day as
well as the at the european level
then obviously the regulation but we
have here very good movements of the
polish national regulator who already
deregulated
some big cities
because the competition of ktv is so
it's it's so strong and third of all
it's obviously the economy but as our
economy is still very nicely growing so
i think that the third element will be
uh somehow managed marcia thanks very
much for talking to us thank you very
much
so a dramatic insight there into poland
one of the fastest growing markets in
europe and how it's dealing with the
various challenges from cities to rural
areas